et le cabba jean frédéric poisson merci
monsieur le président la question
s'adresserait au premier ministre s'il
était encore parmi nous elle porte sur
le taffetas le fameux traité
transatlantique
je suis heureux de confirmer à
l'ensemble de nos collègues ici présent
que les documents portant comptes rendus
des dix premiers rounds de négociation
du traité transatlantiques sont
disponibles et consultables par les
parlementaires français
néanmoins ils le sont dans des
conditions tout à fait spécial dans un
des services du premier ministre dans
une salle fermée en étant escorté par un
fonctionnaire de matignon qui sert de
surveillants en prenant soin de déposer
son téléphone portable à l'entrée pour
ne pas s'en servir en consultant
document qui par ailleurs est en anglais
et avec des sanctions pénales à la clé
pour tout parlementaire qui divulguerait
des informations qu'il a recueillies en
consultant ces documents lorsque je me
suis étonnée hier après-midi de ces
conditions il m'a été répondu que je
cite des directives très précise de la
commission européenne et du gouvernement
des états unis d'amérique
obligé de telles modalités de
consultation et ne pouvait permettre de
procéder autrement
alors monsieur le premier ministre j'ai
deux choses à dire
la première c'est que avec tout le
respect que nous avons ici pour la
commission européenne et pour le
gouvernement américain
ils n'ont pas ni l'un ni l'autre a donné
des consignes de consultation aux
membres du parlement français et la
consultation de ces documents doit se
faire librement dans l'espace public et
sans aucune espèce de limites
la deuxième question elle est simple
quand monsieur le premier ministre
allez vous inscrire comme nous vous
l'avons demandé un bilan étape des
négociations du traité transatlantique
quand allez-vous porter dans l'espace
public tous ces sujets qui concernent la
vie quotidien des français la vie
quotidienne des français et pas des
affaires de technocrates à bruxelles ou
ailleurs quand allons-nous faire de ce
traité un enjeu politique est plus un
enjeu de spécialistes le parlement
l'attend et les français l'attend
la parole est à monsieur mathias fekl
secrétaire d'état chargée du commerce
extérieur de la promotion du tourisme
des français de l'étranger
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jean-frédéric poisson je veux d'abord
vous féliciter d'avoir fait la démarche
que vous avez effectués pour aller
consulter les documents un certain
nombre d'autres parlementaires l'ont
d'ores et déjà fait j'en parlais encore
hier avec monsieur le député hervé
pellois vous avez parfaitement raison de
dire que la transparence est un sujet
majeur dans ces négociations et nous
préférons d'ailleurs vous savoir dans
les locaux de l'administration française
faire de la transparence que dans le
bureau de monsieur el assad en train de
faire je ne sais quel diplomatie
parallèle sur le fond sur le fond parce
que le sujet est sérieux c'est bouclé le
langmann en regard aux gestions aller
j'ai fait de la transparence le coeur de
ce sujet avec un premier aspect qui est
de rendre compte régulièrement devant le
parlement devant vous mesdames et
messieurs les députés devant les
commissions compétentes et devant
l'hémicycle pour la première fois à
d'ailleurs été à mon initiative
présenter un rapport sur le commerce
extérieur français qui présente
publiquement et devant le débat de la
représentation nationale les grandes
stratégies du commerce extérieur la
transparence c'est aussi la publication
du mandat de négociation et c'est
l'ouverture à la demande du gouvernement
français d'une salle de lecture qui
permet aux parlementaires de prendre
connaissance des documents
7 nous avons été parmi les premiers à le
demander et la france a été la première
à rendre cette salle opérationnelle et à
vous permettre d'y avoir accès j'invite
tous les parlementaires d'ailleurs à en
faire usage
vous avez accès aux documents dans les
mêmes conditions que tous les
parlementaires européens et je me suis
battu pour cela en le demandant à
l'ambassadrice des états unis au
représentant spécial du président obama
sur le commerce extérieur et à la
commissaire européenne
c'est un pas très important il ne résume
pas le besoin de transparence qu'il faut
renforcer qui est un enjeu pour le
commerce extérieur de demain
merci me